I'm 63 years of age and I can't keep
being like this Sharon Osbourne is
distraught over her split from Ozzy the
pair called it quits over Ozzy's alleged
affair with his hairstylist now a source
tells et's Sharon discovered Ozzy's
indiscretions by going through his
emails quote Sharon has put up with a
lot over the course of their marriage
but this is the first longtime affair
Sharon has found out about this is an
emotional affair it wasn't just a
one-time hookup I honestly at this point
today have no idea what I'm going to be
doing with the rest of my life this is
like getting to the last chapter of this
book I really want to think about it
very carefully about where I want to go
and our source says their daughter Kelly
is just as hurt quote Kelly feels
betrayed she is very worried about her
mom Sharon revealed she and Ozzy are
living apart but still speaking we're
told there will be a time when Ozzy and
Sharon come together to figure out
logistics quote they're best friends
partners of business partners so many
things that's why this split is so hard
you